I had a lot of great games this year
that I wanted to put in the list shout
out to hohokam but there was one that I
knew had to make it and that was the
vanishing of Ethan Carter and the reason
I did that was accomplishes everything
that it meant to accomplish even in a
short game how immersive the world is
from the second you're put into it how
much it keeps you in suspense and on
your toes and the puzzles actually are
incredibly intriguing and you feel
really smart when you finish them I
think that's something that a lot of
games try to do but they can't
successfully pull it off and the
vanishing of Ethan Carter you're able to
figure out what happened and put them in
the right order and then you get to kind
of watch them play out in this nice
victory this nice feeling that reward
for figuring everything else really
short so it's certainly worth your time
and it's something that stayed with me
throughout the year I'm really glad I
played it I'm really glad that John
McGinnis told me to play in so I'll do
the same in return and everyone should
fry the vanishing of Ethan Carter
rockstar just completely outdid
themselves making a world that just
feels so alive and you don't have to
play the campaign again you can just run
around it's just an amazing lucid world
and you just feel like you are in it
especially now the first person instead
I was Trevor I was kind of like this
insane person but now I'm my own insane
person one of my best moments of 2014
was robbed and I made her own characters
chassis and tong go he's the disgusting
crack-addicted couple that hates and
loves each other we had hours of fun in
this city and it was just like one of
the highlights of my year playing this
disgusting vile creature in this
fantastically real world hats and
monocles like Oh quite so there's a
quality exchange whoa this year there
were so many amazing brawl style games
from smash to nidhogg there was samurai
gun gang beasts one of the ones that was
played in the office so much was tower
fall and there was a reason for that
it's because it just creates these
insane rivals between people arrows are
such a good weapon because they're the
great equalizer you don't really need
power ups you can just be able to have a
fantastic shot sometimes sometimes you
can get killed by a fantastic shots so
it always leads up to these epic moments
i love that the world is alive in the
arenas a lot of times there's active
platforms or things that come alive in
the arenas that can kill you always
leads for a surprise and really really
fun to play amongst people that you love
and hate
it would be impossible to not let dark
souls to be on my list this year because
it impacted so much of my life when I
mean impact my life I mean how many
hours I had to dedicate to this game to
even get remotely close to finishing it
it took so many hours in each boss just
more vicious than the next there were a
few that we're just really amazing there
was this chariot boss and these horses
and this tiny hallway is the kind of
thing that when you when you beat him
you told your friends about it because
it felt really cool and really powerful
no man's Wharf had this boss that a lot
of people actually didn't think was that
tough but I really struggled with it
because water was filling the room so if
you took too long by the time you were
fighting him you had water up to your
waist you couldn't dodge and he was just
impossible to beat and I remember this
so vividly because even though this is a
solo game there's a lot of social
elements to it from bringing in other
people strangers that come and help
fight with you but also in the real
world I remember having a beer with
Vinny from giant bomb and telling him
how much I hated this boss and he gave
me a lot of really good tips on how to
beat him so when I finally did that I
came back and had this like amazing
story about how how awesome I was and
how I actually beat it it felt really
good and so I love that you can find
this solo campaign game that allows you
to actually be incredibly social not
just in gaming but also in the real
world
and for my game of the year which was a
surprise to me actually ended up being
diablo 3 reaper of souls and there's a
million reasons why this just won me
over Mathias is just a vicious
disgusting boss he is terrifying and the
cutscenes are so engrossing there's like
this part really like rips the soul out
of a dude and it hits the water and then
it tries to swim away and my healthiest
like sucks them up anyway it's so gross
it makes you really really want to play
the items are sick and the developers
don't even get enough credit for the art
assets that they create I was a demon
hunter and I had a crossbow that was a
skull that vomited yellow bile it was so
cool the final chapter is the best
chapter you fight in heaven it's
gorgeous it's way better than fighting
in hell it's absolutely beautiful and
it's just like the entire area is
stunning I love customizing my
characters build with the runes and I
like just experimenting and testing them
out I swear I had the best room but it
turns out if I switched it to a
different one my attack speed was so
much faster that it just murdered people
and it ended up being like the perfect
build for my character and I was so
excited that I got to like experiment
and test that out and be rewarded for it
there's torment modes one through six so
that you can like push yourself even
further on the difficulty chain once you
get to level 70 then there's Paragon
levels so that you can just kind of make
yourself even more badass and I found a
rainbow goblin who took me to whimsy
Dale and that was just this ridiculous
complete surprise where I was
transported to a world of green fields
and ponies and I slaughtered them so
it's just constantly filled with
surprises there's more surprised out
there there's so many things I haven't
unlocked yet and I've already spent a
lot of time into it and I can't wait to
spend more time into it and that's why
it is my game of 2014 you haven't picked
it up yet because you didn't like it at
first pick it up again it's better it's
worth playing and I
I'm console it was awesome so don't be
afraid to play it on an xbox one or ps4
the controller is just as good it's
awesome it's such a good game play it
right now go
[Music]
[Music]